,
THANK GOODNESS.
PLEASE, PICK UP ON WHERE YOU
LEFT OFF.
>> SURE, AMARA.
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
THINGS BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE PROGRESS THAT THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE MADE, IT REALLY WAS
SUMMARIZED BY THE PHRASE OF THE
PEOPLE WHEN THEY SAID
[ SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH ], THAT
IS "GLORY TO THE UKRAINIAN
ARMY."
WHAT THEY'RE DOING, UKRAINIANS
ARE MOVING IN A METHODICAL WAY.
FIRST THEIR CAPITAL, THEN MOVED
INTO THE NORTHEAST TO SECURE THE
AREA AROUND KHARKIV AND NOW
AFTERED ONE PROVINCIAL CAPITAL
THAT THE RUSSIANS HAD, KHERSON,
AND NOW ARE MOVING POTENTIALLY
INTO AN AREA WHERE THEY COULD
EVEN THREATEN RUSSIAN CONTROL OF
CRIMEA.
SO THAT, OF COURSE, IS, YOU
KNOW, PERHAPS LITERALLY A BRIDGE
TOO FAR AT THE MOMENT FOR THEM,
BUT THE UKRAINIANS DEFINITELY
HAVE MOMENTUM AND ARE DOING
SOMETHING VERY UNIQUE, VERY
INNOVATIVE WITH THE WESTERN
WEAPONS THEY'RE RECEIVING,
AMARA.
THAT, I THINK IS A HUGE
INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO WARFARE
WE'RE GOING TO STEADY FOR QUITE
SOME TIME.
>> A HUGE MORALE BOOST AND SO
GLAD WE HAVE THE MAP UP THERE.
IF YOU CAN PUT THAT BACK UP YOU
SEE WHERE KHERSON IS LOCATED IN
THE SOUTH.
THIS WAS A STRATEGIC PRIZE FOR
RUSSIA AT THE TIME BECAUSE IT
SERVED AS A LAND BRIDGE, RIGHT,
BETWEEN UKRAINE AND, OF COURSE,
CRIMEA, THAT WAS ILLEGALLY AN
NEXTED BY RUSSIA IN 2014.
SO CEDRIC, WHAT DO YOU EXPECT
THE NEXT STEPS TO BE FOR THE
UKRAINIAN MILITARY?
ESPECIALLY KNOWING THAT THERE
ARE SO MANY MINED AREAS?
>> YEAH.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A MAJOR
URBAN OPERATION.
YOU KNOW, IT'S PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO BE CLASSIC URBAN
WARFARE LIKE YOU SAW IN WORLD
WAR II WITH THE BATTLE OF
STALINGRAD BUT YOU'LL SEE A
METHODICAL OPERATION TO CLEAR
BUILDINGS OF BOOBYTRAPS,
POTENTIAL BOOBYTRAPS, OF MINES,
THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
THE OTHER THING UKRAINIANS HAVE
TO DO, THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
MOVE THEIR SYSTEMS FORWARD SO
THAT THEY CAN COUNTER ANY
POSSIBLE RUSSIAN ARTILLERY THAT
IS GOING TO BE ON THE EASTERN
BANK OF THE DNIPRO RIVER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHERE THINGS
ARE ON THE MAP RIGHT NOW, YOU
CAN SEE THAT THE UKRAINIANS HAVE
MOVED TO THAT RIVER BANK.
THEY ARE NOW CONTROLLING THAT
AREA.
THEY'LL HAVE TO MOP UP SOME
REMAINING, STRAGGLING RUSSIAN
FORCES, THAT DID NOT MAKE IT OUT
OF THE WEST BANK OF THE DNIPRO
RIVER, BUTTED THOSE THAT ARE
THERE WILL PROBABLY BE EITHER
SURRENDER OR IN ESSENCE BE
ELIMINATED FROM THE FIGHT.
SO THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT FOR THE UKRAINIANS.
THEY'LL HAVE TO CONSOLIDATE
THEIR VICTORY HERE AND TO DO
THAT